before we get on with the big one I'd
like to take this opportunity to level
you might say to speak for just a second
to us we in the picture business I for
one and frankly a little tired of all of
the talk about editorials quote what's
wrong with Hollywood unquote I'm sick
about hearing of runaway productions and
costs and the star system and how we
need government subsidies I know it and
you know it but we need a good pictures
and the way to get good pictures is our
rather rather weakly hinted earlier in
the evening is to get back into the mona
lisa business individual pictures
handmade with love and passion and care
by individual picture makers not by
banks of committees or accountants or
lawyers or office boys or boards of
directors who are really in the real
estate business but by picture makers
now tomorrow morning a focal place boy
is going to throw a newspaper on your
front lawn and when you turn to the
entertainment section there will be an
ad which reads the best picture of the
year we are about to write that ad now
and to help us write it we decided on a
French housewife born in Tokyo naturally
we had our choice of all of the French
housewives born in Tokyo but since this
show calls for an Oscar winner
we picked the girl who hit the Academy
Daily Double first for her performance
in to each his own and then the heiress
ladies and gentlemen miss Olivia de
Havilland